J'ai remarqué une chose, c'est que
quand je vous fais des vidéos qui parlent de bio,
ça a l'air de vous intéresser vachement moins
que la physique fondamentale
et pourtant je vais quand même continuer.
La technique dont je veux vous parler aujourd'hui
porte un nom un petit peu barbare,
elle s'appelle CRISPR/Cas9,
et pourtant je suis sûr que quand
vous aurez fini de regarder cette vidéo,
vous serez content d'en avoir entendu parler
parce qu'il s'agit d'une technique qui va
très certainement révolutionner la génétique.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Ces derniers temps, on entend assez régulièrement
parler de l'idée de faire des manipulations génétiques,
que ce soit pour faire des OGM
ou bien faire de la thérapie génique.
Pourtant, aller modifier le génome d'une plante ou
d'un animal ou, à plus forte raison, d'un être humain,
ce n'est quand même pas si simple que ça.
Ajouter un gène nouveau à un organisme,
c'est quelque chose qu'on arrive parfois à faire.
A l'inverse, atténuer un gène, dans certaines
circonstances on peut le faire aussi.
Mais ce qui est particulièrement difficile,
c'est d'aller directement modifier un gène dans l'ADN,
en tous cas, c'est un petit peu plus compliqué que d'aller
corriger des fautes avec un traitement de texte.
Enfin ça c'était avant, puisque avec CRISPR,
la technique dont je vais vous parler aujourd'hui,
vous allez voir que aller modifier
un gène directement dans l'ADN
est devenu presque aussi facile que d'utiliser
un traitement de texte... enfin presque.
Comme souvent en sciences, tout ça
a commencé d'une manière un peu fortuite
et assez éloignée de ce qu'on allait en faire à la fin.
Il y a une trentaine d'années, des chercheurs Japonais
ont découvert dans le génome d'une bactérie
des petites séquences répétées qui sont des palindromes.
Un palindrome c'est un mot qui peut
se lire dans les deux sens
comme bob, rotor ou encore ressasser.
D'accord, mais un palindrome d'ADN, ça veut dire quoi ?
Pour comprendre, il faut commencer
par rappeler ce que c'est que l'ADN.
L'ADN est une longue molécule qui est formée
de briques élémentaires qu'on appelle les bases.
Il y a quatre bases possibles
et on les désigne par les lettres A, T, G et C.
Donc votre génome, mon génome, le génome
du concombre que j'ai mangé tout à l'heure,
tout ça se résume à une longue
suite de lettres parmi ces quatre.
Ce qu'ont remarqué nos chercheurs Japonais en 1987,
c'est que dans le génome de certaines bactéries,
on trouvait des séquences d'ADN en palindromes,
c'était des séquences qui faisaient
à peu près une trentaine de bases
et entre ces séquences, on avait des séquences
normales qui faisaient à peu près la même taille
et ce sont ces petites séquences palindromes
qu'on a plus tard appelées CRISPR
pour: Clustered Regularly Interspaced
Short Palindromic Repeats.
A l'époque ces chercheurs n'avaient absolument
aucune idée de ce à quoi servaient ces palindromes
et en fait les choses en sont restées là
pendant à peu près une vingtaine d'années
jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un découvre
que l'important dans l'histoire,
ce n'était pas les palindromes,
c'était ce qu'il y avait entre les palindromes
parce que ces séquences intermédiaires sont
en fait exactement identiques à de l'ADN de virus.
Oui, c'est ça, de l'ADN de virus au milieu de l'ADN des bactéries.
Vous vous demandez peut-être pourquoi des bactéries
posséderaient de l'ADN d'un virus,
et bien c'est pour se défendre contre lui
parce que les virus sont encore plus petits que les bactéries
et donc certains virus sont susceptibles d'infecter les bactéries
de la même manière qu'ils nous infectent nous.
D'ailleurs, il y a toute une classe de virus
qu'on appelle des bactériophages
et ils ont une forme que, personnellement,
je trouve absolument incroyable,
on croirait qu'ils sont sortis d'un film de science fiction
genre La Guerre des Mondes.
Là par exemple, on voit des bactériophages
en train d'infecter une bactérie.
Donc, comment font les bactéries
pour se défendre contre ces virus
et bien elles essayent de conserver un petit bout de leur ADN,
ce qui leur permet de les identifier
et de les détruire si jamais ils se recroisent.
Vous savez, c'est un petit peu analogue
au principe de la vaccination,
pour certaines maladies, notre organisme
a une forme de mémoire
et le fait d'avoir déjà été exposé une fois
permet de se défendre par la suite.
Ces séquences mystérieuses qui se trouvent entre
les palindromes, c'est ça la mémoire des bactéries,
c'est un petit peu comme si les bactéries
gardaient une photo de leur agresseur
pour être capables de l'identifier par la suite.
Finalement, ces petits bouts d'ADN, c'est un peu
le principe de l'affiche "On recherche mort ou vif".
Notez d'ailleurs que c'est un mécanisme qui est
vachement plus efficace que notre vaccination
puisque le fait qu'il soit dans l'ADN
fait qu'il est héréditaire et il se transmet
de générations en générations.
Moi, le fait que mon père se soit fait vacciner
contre la tuberculose quand il était jeune
ne me donne pas son immunité,
je suis obligé de me refaire vacciner,
alors que ces bactéries qui ont stocké
de l'ADN de virus dans leur propre ADN
vont passer cette mémoire à toute leur descendance.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Je vous ai dit que ces petits morceaux
d'ADN de virus que les bactéries stockent
jouent un peu le rôle des affiches "On recherche mort ou vif",
alors tout ça c'est très bien, mais pour que le système
fonctionne, il faut l'équivalent du chasseur de primes,
vous savez, celui qui va regarder l'affiche et qui
va ensuite trouver le méchant pour le buter.
♪ [Bande sonore de western] ♪
Ces chasseurs de primes, dans le cas des bactéries,
se sont des enzymes qu'on appelle CAS.
Ces enzymes sont capables d'aller retrouver de l'ADN de virus
et de le découper pour le neutraliser.
Mais pour comprendre vraiment comment ça se passe,
il faut aller un petit peu dans les détails.
Une chose que vous savez peut-être,
c'est que l'ADN n'est en général pas utilisé tel quel,
nos cellules fabriquent d'abord
un intermédiaire qu'on appelle l'ARN
qui est une molécule à un seul brin
qui est complémentaire de l'ADN
et qui contient essentiellement la même information.
Donc, la fabrication de l'ARN à partir de l'ADN,
c'est l'étape qu'on appelle la transcription.
Voilà comment marche le mécanisme de défense.
Quand une bactérie subit une agression,
elle se met à faire la transcription de toute la partie de l'ADN
dans lequel il y a les palindromes
et les petits morceaux d'ADN de virus.
Les petits bouts d'ARN qui correspondent aux séquences
intermédiaires sont donnés aux protéines CAS
et les protéines CAS les utilisent,
en quelque sorte, comme photo d’identification.
Ces protéines CAS se baladent ensuite dans la bactérie
et si elles trouvent un bout d'ADN qui colle avec leur ARN,
c'est qu'il appartient à un virus donc
elles s'y accrochent et le découpent.
Donc vous voyez qu'au total, ces bactéries
possèdent un système qui est absolument génial
qui leur permet d'aller identifier des petits bouts
ciblés d'ADN et d'aller les découper.
Ça c'est la nature qui nous le donne
et c'est là qu'intervient l'idée géniale,
celle d'utiliser ce système pour
aller faire de la chirurgie du génome.
La mise en place de cette idée est due
essentiellement à deux femmes scientifiques,
une Américaine, Jennifer Doudna
et une Française, Emmanuelle Charpentier.
Doudna et Charpentier ont travaillé ensemble avec
une enzyme CAS particulière qu'on appelle la CAS9
et elles ont montré que cette enzyme,
on pouvait la programmer
pour qu'elle aille découper
des petits bouts d'ADN de manière ciblée
et ça, pas seulement avec de l'ADN de virus.
Imaginons qu'on repère un gène dans une cellule
et qu'on ait envie d'aller le découper
et bien il suffit de refiler l'ARN
correspondant à une enzyme CAS9,
d'injecter tout ça dans la cellule
et CAS9 va trouver la cible et la découper
comme si elle croyait attaquer un virus.
CAS9 est, en gros, l'équivalent de "Rechercher
et Couper", vous savez, "Ctrl + F, Ctrl + X".
Alors, "Rechercher, Couper" c'est bien,
mais ce qui serait encore mieux ça serait
de pouvoir faire "Rechercher, Remplacer",
c'est-à-dire d'être capable d'aller cibler
une séquence donnée de l'ADN,
de l'enlever et de la remplacer par quelque chose d'autre.
Ça, Doudna et Charpentier ont montré
que ça marchait assez facilement
parce qu'il existe un mécanisme de réparation dans
les cellules qu'on appelle la recombinaison homologue
qui fait que, si jamais il y a
un morceau d'ADN qui est endommagé,
les cellules vont, en permanence, essayer de le restaurer.
Le petit miracle c'est que, imaginons que vous vouliez
couper un gène et le remplacer par une variante de ce gène,
vous programmez CAS9 pour faire la découpe,
ensuite vous injectez dans le coin
le nouveau gène que vous voulez faire
et grâce au mécanisme de recombinaison homologue,
c'est votre nouveau gène qui va être pris
et utilisé pour faire la réparation
et donc vous aurez remplacé un gène dans l'ADN.
Grâce à CAS9 et au mécanisme de la recombinaison homologue,
vous aurez pu faire "Rechercher, Remplacer" dans de l'ADN.
C'est pas génial ça ?!
En fait, en soi, ce n'est pas complètement nouveau,
il existait déjà des techniques qui permettaient de faire ça,
mais ça coûtait très très cher et c'était très très long
parce qu'il fallait designer une protéine spécifique
suivant le gène que vous vouliez remplacer.
Ce qui est magique avec CAS9,
c'est que vous utilisez une seule protéine
et simplement vous la programmez différemment
avec un petit bout d'ARN qui va bien.
Il faut évidemment des techniques
de microbiologie pour faire ça,
mais pour vous donner une idée de à quel point c'est simple,
si vous savez quelle séquence d'ADN vous voulez cibler,
il existe une boite qui va vous fournir le petit bout d'ARN
correspondant en quelques jours, pour seulement 65$.
Evidemment, la découverte et la mise au point de
cette technique a fait l'effet d'une bombe en biologie
et tout le monde s'est mis à l'appliquer
à à peu près tout et n'importe quoi.
A des bactéries bien sûr, mais aussi à des levures,
à des vers, à des poissons, à des souris
et bien sûr, au bout d'un moment
à des cellules humaines... et ça marche partout
♪ [Générique] ♪
CRISPR, ou plutôt l'enzyme CAS9, c'est donc
la possibilité d'aller modifier à volonté
n'importe quel morceau d'ADN d'à peu près
n'importe quelle espèce
et évidemment ça ouvre des perspectives formidables
pour la recherche en biologie et en médecine.
Par exemple, on peut utiliser cette technique
pour savoir à quoi sert un gène.
Vous savez, on a séquencé le génome de tout un tas d'espèces,
mais dire qu'on a séquencé le génome ne veut pas dire
qu'on comprend à quoi sert chacun des gènes,
au contraire, il n'y a qu'une poignée
de gènes qu'on comprend vraiment.
Donc grâce à la technique CAS9,
on peut aller modifier ou découper un gène
et regarder ce qu'il se passe
pour comprendre à quoi servait ce gène.
Evidemment, quand on parle de manipulation
du génome, on pense tout de suite aux OGM.
Alors, les OGM dans nos assiettes, c'est vrai
que ce n'est pas forcement hyper ragoûtant,
mais il faut bien voir qu'il y a d'autres applications des OGM.
Par exemple, l'insuline que des millions
de diabétiques s'injectent chaque jour
est faite à partir d'une bactérie OGM à qui on a introduit
un nouveau gène, le gène de l'insuline humaine,
pour que ces bactéries produisent de l'insuline humaine.
Cet exemple là en particulier est ancien donc
il n'a pas été fait avec la méthode CRSPR et CAS9,
mais le fait que cette nouvelle technique soit facile et disponible
ouvre tout un tas d'applications du même genre.
Par exemple, il y a des gens qui essayent
de modifier grâce à CAS9
le génome de certaines levures
pour leur faire produire des biocarburants.
Il y a évidemment tout un tas d'applications
pour essayer de produire des céréales
qui résisteraient mieux aux maladies
comme le mildiou, par exemple
et puis il y a même un projet complètement fou
de gens qui essayent de modifier l'ADN des moustiques
pour les rendre résistants à la malaria.
La malaria, ou le palud c'est la même chose, je rappelle
que c'est quand même le plus gros assassin de la planète
puisqu'il cause 650 000 morts par an.
Il faut bien voir qu'un des avantages de CAS9 par rapport
aux manipulations génétiques qu'on pouvait faire avant,
c'est que c'est un outil extrêmement précis, on va vraiment juste remplacer ce qu'on a besoin
et donc ça limite grandement les risques
d'avoir des effets secondaires.
Sur le plan thérapeutique, cette technique là
suscite aussi pas mal d'espoirs,
vous savez peut-être qu'il y a beaucoup de maladies génétiques
qui sont parfois dues au dysfonctionnement d'un seul gène
et donc si on était capables de traiter ce gène,
on pourrait guérir les personnes correspondantes.
C'est le cas, par exemple, de la mucoviscidose qui est causée
par la mutation d'un seul gène qu'on appelle CFTR
ou encore de la myopathie qui est causée par
une mutation du gène DMD et il y en a plein d'autres,
la maladie de Huntington,
la drépanocytose, l'hémophilie, etc...
Evidemment, faire des modifications génétiques comme
ça chez un adulte, ça s'annonce quand même compliqué
parce qu'on a des milliards de cellules dans le corps
et donc on a des milliards de copies d'ADN
donc on imagine qu'il faudrait aller toutes les corriger
pour complètement guérir une maladie.
Mais si on imagine faire une modification
du génome juste après la fécondation,
au moment où l'embryon n'est constitué que d'une seule cellule,
il n'y a qu'une seule copie de l'ADN à corriger
pour faire complètement disparaître la maladie.
Donc il y a quelques mois, des scientifiques ont montré
que c'était possible de faire ça sur un singe macaque,
ils ont fait une fécondation in-vitro, ensuite grâce à CAS9
ils sont allés modifier l'ADN de l'embryon
et ensuite ils ont réimplanté l'embryon dans une mère porteuse.
La mère porteuse a finalement donné naissance
à un animal viable dont l'ADN avait été modifié.
Evidemment, je pense que vous voyez où je veux en venir,
si on est capables d'aller modifier individuellement
des cellules d'un embryon pour trafiquer leur ADN,
ça ouvre la voie à de l'eugénisme.
Récemment, un groupe de recherche
de l'université Sun Yat-sen en Chine
a franchi ce que certains considèrent comme la ligne rouge,
puisqu'ils ont été, grâce à CAS9, faire de la modification
de l'ADN d'embryons humains.
Il faut bien noter qu'ils ont fait ça en utilisant
des embryons qui de toute façon n'étaient pas viables
et qu'ils ont fait ça, à priori, pour la bonne cause
puisque c'était pour montrer qu'on pouvait guérir chez
ces embryons une maladie qu'on appelle la thalassémie.
Mais quand même pour la première fois, on a fait
de la manipulation génétique de l'ADN d'un embryon humain
et donc même si ça suscite des espoirs,
ça fait quand même un peu froid dans le dos.
Je pense que vous comprenez maintenant pourquoi
je tenais absolument à vous parler de CRISPR et CAS9
parce que c'est une technique qui s'est développée
vraiment à une vitesse fulgurante, en quelques années
et elle permet de faire des choses
qu'on pensait totalement inaccessibles avant
et donc il va falloir qu'il y ait
de sérieux débats bioéthiques qui aient lieu
pour décider quels sont les usages acceptables
de cette technique sur l'être humain
et à la vitesse à laquelle vont les choses, à mon avis,
il vaudrait mieux ne pas trop tarder pour que ce débat ait lieu.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, même si c'était de la bio,
si elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas à la partager.
Comme d'habitude vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne,
me retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux, Facebook, Twitter.
Ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir sur Tipeee,
un grand merci à tous les tipeurs
et vous pouvez aussi me retrouver sur mon blog
qui s'appelle Science Étonnante.
Merci, à bientôt.